في تطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا اعلنت كياف ان روسيا جنه هجمات
صاروخيه جديده على اوديسا
وكيافولوجيا استهدفت منشات للطاقه ومصنع
للسواريقه اذا الاشتباكات والمعارك والقصف
يتواصل منذ 2007 و 60 يوما على بدايه
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
العسكريه انها اسقط الطائرتين انتحاريتين
فوق سد كياف للطاقه الكهربائيه
فقدت انفجارات عده عقب غارات للطيران
الروسي وادت الى انقطاع الكهرباء في
المدينه وقال رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني من
القصفه السهدفا منشاته بنا تحتيه ومصنعا
للصواريخ في المقاطعه اما فيه وليس فقد
قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه ان قصف عن استهدف
البنيه التحتيه في المدينه واسفل عن جرحه
كما قالت انها اسقطت عددا من الطائرات غير
وصاروخ كروز هاجمت بها القوات الروسيه
المدينه في الجانب الذي تسيطر عليه روسيا
اعلنت السلطات المواليه لها اصابه مدنيين
وتدمير عدد من المنازل ومنشات البنيه
التحتيه وذلك جراء القذف الاوكراني لعدد
من المناطق في اقليم دون بس كل هذا القصف
ياتي في ظل استمرار المعارك الاسيه ما في
الجبهه الشرقيه حيث قالت مصادر عسكريه
لمراسل الجزيره ان اعنف الاشتباكات هناك
تجري على جبهتين باخمود